bootleg cat podcast man G Perico in the
building the gangster girls drops Friday
Thursday night if you're on the west
coast let's get right to it man
get it
yeah
uh-huh
yeah yeah
I want everything I got coming if it's
love if it's beef if it's money real
success like a chef chopping onions
these always crying about
something I'm International ratchet
irrational finally said it that's
just something that I had to do turning
up the click that's just something that
I had to prove back against the wall it
was nothing that I had to lose they
calling me in from the PNG do your
am I being super high off of Euro this
millionaire so I got me a trigger man
all these rappers getting killed I can't
let them kill the bag I ain't have a dad
so I looked up to that back at 13
I was covered up in blue rags in 23 all
I'm going for is blue bags the
opportunity is Slim So I gotta move fast
The Trenches got wearing Dentures
AR-15s knocking out existence
yeah that ain't nowhere in my vision I'm
on defense and offense G keep killing
the mo that I make the crazier I feel I
thank God every day I can't believe this
is real gotta get a bigger bag
cause my need appeals I got 700k
for my negotiating skill yeah
um and that's for one album I up
any way that I come at them that goes to
show ain't no dumb rapper all these
got opinions but it don't matter
I pulled up to the hood then I flew
straight up out the country I'm looking
good smelling good we know who getting
money it's the click click click click
click click click to Keep it Gangster I
deserve all this Enterprise click
baby 2023 and Beyond this don't
stop we taking over bootleg care yes sir
one of the only that could
get me to do this you know what I'm
saying let's go let's go hey I know you
just watched a new freestyle guess what
we're dropping them every week sometimes
more than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at a checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week